sur scène elles sont deux de bigote deux
femmes à la langue bien pendue alors si
elle aime beaucoup chantelle mon dieu
elle aime aussi beaucoup le ragot et le
poncif surtout quand ça concerne les
étrangers
mais si le tueur qui était pas passé par
là s'il n'était pas passé par là c'est
une pièce coup de poing en pleine
lecture qui conduisent tous et turquie a
de quoi avoir peur
deux femmes deux vieilles filles qui
commente la mort d'un des leurs monsieur
gasset et 15h récemment renversé par un
city stade du ray ya turquie est passée
juste là beaucoup trop bu et conduisent
comme des fous et vous fiche la trouille
en conduisant comme ça cette racaille en
conduisant comme ça quel pauvre monsieur
ce monsieur kalt rattner qu'elle aime
bien qu'elle philanthrope
de nos jours on peut plus traverser la
rue sans avoir peur je pense que ce qui
est fort dans la mise en scène de thomas
gaubiac c'est que on s'attache à elle et
que tout d'un coup on s'aperçoit quand
on est spectateur qu'on ait pris en
otage parce qu'on s'aperçoit que ces
gens là tiennent des discours qui sont
pas possible que c'est des monstres
naissant et donc on s'aperçoit qu'en fin
de compte on est tous un peu être un
monstre demain pour une raison ou pour
une autre on est peut-être le monstre de
demain raciste et bigote parce qu'elles
s'ennuient leur activité principale
c'est la répétition des chants de metz
sur fond de patriotisme forcément
le personnage il est il est bien il
n'est pas il n'est pas stupide mais il
est un petit peu limité on va dire il
ils disent que pensent les autres il n'y
a pas vraiment de de pensée individuelle
consciente et personnelles et votre
corps
veuillez nous excuser pour cette
interruption note
le mois de marie de thomasz bernard
oscille entre le drame et la farce petit
bijou de 30 minutes à ne surtout pas
rater
c'est un duo inédit et audacieux l'inde
ans tout en improvisation l'autre joue
du clavecin répertoire issu du xviie et
xviiie siècles
chaque concert est donc unique la
violence dans tous ses états au cdn
d'orléans avec violente femmes
un docu-fiction une pièce de théâtre
pour dénoncer l'horreur
il est auteur compositeur interprète il
est aussi peintre et photographe
le britannique piers faccini est un
artiste complet et il est en concert à
saint jean de la ruelle
j'aime le piquant pas trop de doses à un
univers personnel coloré une intimité
revendiquer et un premier cd dans les
bacs la tourangelle comme dalles se
produit ce soir à la pléiade
carmen au zénith pendant trois jours un
projet coopératif signé la fabrique
opéra pour que l'art lyrique ne soit pas
réservée à une élite
et on termine avec cette expo qui va
vous étonner
à commencer par son titre le singe qui
lèche une déambulation artistique autour
de l'espace